soeul scrolls are the bad guys they're
shapeshifters noble warrior hero what do
they not that's what I'm here to find
out
don't answer that
war is coming
you can't do this alone
know your enemy what are you telling me
would you like to know what you really
are
Captain Marvel with a pg-13 ticket snap
hey everyone it's Warren and we have a
brand new TV spot for Captain Marvel
like most TV spots it's only 30 seconds
long but we have some new footage and
some new dialogue to break down the
first news scene we have is of a Skrull
shape-shifting to look like a human this
happens on the same train scene where
Captain Marvel punches the old lady who
is actually a Skrull in the face they
begin to fight until Captain Marvel
crushes the scrolls face it's unknown if
the scroll who shape-shifted into this
lady is the same scroll whose shape
shifts into this man but judging by the
scene it does appear that way we know
from other trailers that Captain Marvel
ends up chasing the scroll and this is
the scroll that she ends up fighting on
top of the Train and shooting her energy
blasts at we then have a new scene with
Carol Danvers and Monica Rambeau Monica
is a fellow pilot of Carol in the air
force judging by this scene and what
we've seen in other trailers Monica is
going to play a pretty big role in
helping carol danvers recover her memory
of her past life on earth in the scene
Captain Marvel is at Monica's house and
somebody knocks on the door Carol tells
her not to answer it because it's most
likely at this point in time in the
movie the scroll are looking for her as
well as the creep again Captain Marvel
realizes that she had some sort of life
on Earth before she was with the Kree so
she's trying to recover these memories
but the Kree are the ones who wiped her
memory in the first place so obviously
they don't want her to do that and the
scrolls are trying to take over the
earth and Captain Marvel is a big threat
as well so obviously they want to take
her out too we then get a really cool
shot and a really close-up look at a
scroll in what looks to be the crash
scene where Carol Danvers gets her
powers one thing that's new about this
trailer that's actually pretty important
is the dialogue that's being spoken over
some of the scenes Nick Fury is asking
Carol Danvers about the scroll and about
the Kree Carol explains that the scroll
are the villains and Nick Fury asked
well what do they want
and that's when Carol says that's what
I'm here to find out this gives us a
little more insight of why Carol Danvers
is back on earth because we know the
Kree wipe her memory so she doesn't know
that she's actually lived on earth
before that's where she was born and
raised
so she's sent to earth by the Kree for a
mission and based off what we've heard
in this new TV spot it seems like she's
there to
investigate the scroll invasion and
that's it for the new Captain Marvel TV
spot we got a little more new footage
and some new dialogue that helps us
further understand the movie so be sure
to let me know what you think of this
new Captain Marvel TV spot in the
comments down below also I started a new
giveaway if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win five imax tickets so you
and your friends can go see Captain
Marvel or Avengers in-game in IMAX all
you have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to
Captain Marvel Avengers in game and all
things Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]